hmm some people are gonna be really
upset by this by the way hi it's me
again
Zakia and pastry director of craveable
Hospitality Group I have been a
professional pastry chef for 13 years
today we're gonna taste some Girl Scout
cookies and iconic Girl Scout cookie the
exterior doesn't really give away the
true magic that's hidden inside like
many things in life the beauty is within
texture of the cookie is great it has a
subtle hint of mint too much mint and it
becomes like toothpaste my one problem
is the outside coating it's a little
waxy like a mint scented Yankee Candle
four and a half stars we're starting hi
[Music]
this is like when you get a patch for
wrestling a bear it's even better that
it's edible this is better than I
remember there's like a little bit of
saltiness in there and it's really
crunchy these are actually really good
she's a natural beauty she doesn't wear
makeup she just naturally glows I'm like
into it four stars Savannah Smiles
sounds like a drag queen oh that's
interesting
super crunchy crumbly on the inside
super super acidic you eat it and like
you pucker and you do this thing and
then when the sour goes away you finally
smile Savannah Smiles few stars
[Music]
the dosey doe uglier cousin of the
Nutter Butter suspiciously lacking in
filling it's like peanut butter and
chocolate flavor is really good I just
want more cream filling gonna go with
three stars if you promise me a sandwich
it better be heavy on the meat oh these
are no good Girl Scouts more doesn't
really look like a s'more these look
like those sugar-free sandwich cookies
that my grandmother had it's good I'm
not sure it's like s'mores cookies good
basic chocolate is awesome I'm just
missing the toast s'mores is the new
girl I'm gonna be nice I'm gonna give
her three and a half stars a galan for
peanut butter patties depending on where
you live in the country I used to love
these not as good as I remember I want
more peanut butter I want more peanut
the chocolates great I'm just not
getting the creaminess I want this to be
the love child of a peanut butter cup
and a cookie
it looks more like it's cookie father
than it definitely needs milk three and
a half stars three and three-quarter
stars it's like one of those things that
are maybe best kept as a memory
[Music]
Wow they look artisanal gluten-free Girl
Scout cookies next year they're gonna be
selling kale and quinoa salad but no
really for people who can't have gluten
I'm actually really happy that they did
this this is the toffee tester who names
Girl Scout cookies how do I get that job
mmm the box don't lie it's toffee tester
super crunchy nicely caramelized really
great flavor I'm into it good three and
a half stars the only thing missing in
here a lot more toffee I want to crack
it too it's like a thing of beauty that
texture a toasted coconut halo toasty
coconut a hint of suntan lotion in the
best possible way gooey chewy probably
the only Girl Scout cookie that I can't
make better five stars because you can
never replicate perfection were to rush
this box there's like winter spring
summer fall and Girl Scout cookie season
that's my favorite season they're
nostalgic there isn't a bad one go
support your local Girl Scouts buy as
many boxes as you can because no one can
say no to Girl Scout cookies I used to
hide these under my bed like other boys
had filthy magazines I had boxes of Girl
Scout cookies go figure
[Music]